Bài lại thực phẩm hề bị cảm cung nên bột xung,
cơ sông hơi hả đôi khi khi kinh bạn không thể chế khỏi những cân bưa bất chật.
Phần những khi thời gian tâm mua,
giải sản đến việc cơ thể thử xin mắt các bạn cảm cung.
Phải nên, trên một xong hề của viên ý,
khi không này sẽ mấy bạn bài lại thực phẩm cân được bột xung,
khi không nay bị cảm cung, một chào dung ra.
Chào dung ra, là lại thực phẩm có khả năng cung cân cân đủ cho phing dẫn trong hề bị cảm cung.
Nại lại rất sẽ ăn,
cung cân lại được nước phẩm môi đã bị mắt trong cơ thể.
Là bầu xung điểm vitamin, khoảng sức bố tình tình thiệt.
Hai, thường,
bình là mình lượng dân ra có công xung liệu chỉ cảm cung hiệu qua.
Môi phải nên hình trong đoán,
hộng nước uống có công xung dải phing môi số chữ chứng của cảm cung.
Yêu đau đau hậu, ở nệng,
bà, in mạch, khi bị cảm cung,
ăn một tốt chào yên mạch sẽ dù mạng hồi phục xúc khả những chống.
Chông yên mạch chưa có thánh phần dính dưỡng.
Nhưng chất sơ bị ta của Ruhkan,
chất trong ô gì vào,
một lý phy nôn, vitamin nè,
bốn tỏi.
Tỏ không chỉ là một lại ra vị,
mà còn làm một vị thuốc chứng bệnh rất phủ biến.
Người bị cảm cung ăn nhiều tỏi,
sẽ giúp tăng cường hệ miếng dịch.
Nông thời gian có chữa chứng của bệnh.
Năm, các thực phẩm dầu kẻm,
theo biểu chinh nhóm thực phẩm dầu kẻm là thịt bò.
Chông ở trong ngang thịt bò thánh,
có tối bố phy không nằm bị lý gàm kẻm.
Mà ra trong thịt bò, còn ra xấu có Ruhin,
mạch dê, cà li và vitamin bây xấu.
Năm, một cuộc sình phương trong người địa cảm cuốn,
suy bánh nhân mâu trong hồi xức và cải thiền hiện miếng dịch.
Sau chế kê nhiều vitamin c,
anh nhiều chế kê chỉ ở vitamin c,
không bao giờ lại thử bố người địa cảm.
Ví tà miếng dần mai cho quan trọng trong hệ tăng cường khả năng hật động của hệ miếng dịch.
Dung ở địa cảm nhìn hồi xúc hơn.
Bày, sẽ chua, sẽ chua ngôi trở thành thường hiện miếng dịch.
Bà xác dữ cân ra học hiệu quả.
Cung có mọi lượng của Ruhin, thế đi ở xấu có thể.
Sau đó, anh sẽ chua mọi người nhiều tăng dụng rất tất chông người địa cảm cuốn.
Chua mọi người nừng có một sự khẻ thật tóc,
một năng lượng tịch vài đề tên hưởng của sống xin nhẹ thế nhé.